you are facing off against one of the
top centers in the game today the future
of the lead and you are playing on his
court under his rules
against mr. Shawn your team is better
Shawn you own this court with tight
controls a more fleshed out and engaging
career mode numerous reasons to invest
in your character and a fine attention
to detail
NBA Live 19 is a surprisingly big drive
forward for EA's pro basketball
franchise however its numerous
inescapable issues and lack of
significant updates to franchise mode
like the newest entry we're only like an
iterative update on last year's game
basketball is a fast and fluid game and
NBA Live 19 excels in replicating this
on the court there are a number of
impressive details that NBA Live 19
replicates authentically including the
transition from jog to run to sprint how
bodies collide when you drive the lane
and the way a player falls to the ground
in embarrassment when they get their
ankles broken by a well-timed crossover
player specific moves like James Harden
celebrations are brought into the game
with the fine attention to detail the
player models are more realistic looking
though close-up shots during free throws
and replays can look a little off
another issue is that bounce passes
almost never look right with the ball
zipping to the recipient at an inhumanly
fast pace and sometimes at impossible
angles ai logic also has problems
players can make odd decisions like
fouling on 3s consistently and making
obviously errant and silly passes these
abnormalities are unfortunately common
and they are significant enough to take
you out of the game on the presentation
side
NBA Live 19 captures the atmosphere of
professional games and basketball
culture in general in professional games
the crowd noise soars when you make a
big shot shoes squeak as players
scramble for position players slam into
the stanchion after a big play and you
hear the announcer talking about
everyone getting free pizza or tacos if
the home team scores X number of points
it's impressively close to what you'd
see on an NBA broadcast
three on that truck street games also
faithfully capture a very different
subset of basketball culture there's
something special about playing outdoors
and NBA Live 19 nails the presentation
of its blacktop courts and atmosphere of
fans crowded around the edges trying to
get a glimpse the controls in NBA Live
19 are relatively simple but contained
the depth necessary to let you play with
your own style moving the ball around to
create scoring lanes is a fine way to
play but there's room to emphasize more
stylish and exciting moves ankle
breaking crossovers behind the back
dribble step backs and spin moves can
all be performed with the flick of the
stick in the right direction
at the right time executing a play
requires strategy and timing and it all
feels fluid as your teammates will for
the most part make smart cuts to get
free NBA LIVE 19 on the court gameplay
is the best it has ever been
mb a live 19's broadcast presentation is
one of its strongest components the game
continues to use the ESPN license which
brings the big-time Sports network's
graphics trademark music and commentator
Jalen Rose to the game for halftime
highlights and breakdowns in a further
bid for realism that enhances the
experience what's more I brought in a
new commentary team for NBA Live 19
composed of edy cohen and jay williams
they work well together but the
commentary eventually grows stale and
this is particularly apparent when
playing in franchise mode where you
stick with the same players all the time
as it does with the madden series ea
plans to update
NBA Live 19's commentary throughout the
season to keep things fresh and that's
fortunate because new and different
lines are what the game needs
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the most substantial and
noteworthy additions to last year's game
was the RPG light career mode the one it
returns in NBA Live 19 and it genuinely
feels like it is improved with a more
fleshed out story and the introduction
of a deep new mode called court battles
and the ability to create a female
character and customize your own court
your journey in the one takes you to
notable real-world courts in
Philadelphia Paris and Brazil the
diversity of courts and their related
aesthetics like the Eiffel Tower in the
background and colourful structures in
Brazil give you the sense that you're
going on a journey as you try to become
well the one
there are also some fun narrative
choices you can make with your mentor
and agents and this kind of control
helps you feel more connected to the
player you create and more attached to
their journey progression in the one is
akin to an RPG where you'll spend skill
points to increase attributes like
passing rebounding dribbling and
shooting
there are also traits to unlock and
upgrade over your career that
effectively act as perks that help you
improve your game winning tournaments in
the one less you recruit NBA and WNBA
players to your team it's a wonderful
fantasy fulfillment for basketball fans
to build a team of players that can be
comprised of any pro player big focus of
NBA Live 19 is its card collecting
Ultimate Team mode which fans of EA
sports games will know well there are a
mountain of fantasy challenges available
right at the start more than a thousand
in all I had fun earning new players and
completing the challenges but the
overall experience feels very grinding
right anticipation alternatively you can
spend real money on NBA points to buy
new players that you could use
immediately the option to pay is front
and center in Ultimate Team menus and
this feels like an unnecessary and gross
if unsurprising push towards
microtransactions another area that left
me disappointed was franchise mode there
are some noteworthy new updates
including a pre draft preview while the
introduction of bird rights expands and
improves on last year's shallow contract
negotiation options however with no
player editor or online functionality
franchise remains a bare-bones
experience that comes nowhere close to
what EA's other sports games offer NBA
Live 19 also offers numerous online
modes including the standard
head-to-head matches and deeper more
interesting ones like live run and live
events part of what I liked so much
about playing basketball in real life is
the community aspect of playing together
with friends or strangers on a court
down the street NBA Live 19 captures
that feeling and delivers a rewarding
experience for engaging in it NBA Live
19 is a capable and competent basketball
game that offers a multitude of
different ways to play and numerous
reasons to keep coming back it's
impressive attention to detail
complements the strong foundation set by
its presentation and gameplay the AI
logic and animation problems are
impossible to ignore
given they're at the heart of the
experience the entire game is based on
and these issues detract from what is an
otherwise solid basketball game
attack mode isn't a switch that you can
just turn on and off he needs to do more
then we need to see him penetrate get
into that Lane and create color he's
denied that's why I rim protector is a
necessity in this game
what was